welcome Europe you
group you have some sense of here
Street and the importance
I'm a goddess Smith of the history
department former Denison of this
building and it's a great pleasure first
to acknowledge and thank the grandson of
Colonel house who was here a talkin
clause and it's Ed's inspiration and
support that led to persuading our
speaker and author to undertake this
wonderful book now published by the Yale
University Press
I want to welcome
Godfrey Hodgson and introduce him as one
of a line of people from Great Britain
who say going back to James Bryce more
than a century ago have helped Americans
understand themselves and have helped
the people of Great Britain understand
Americans I think also of someone who is
half contemporary overlapping with
Godfrey Alastair Cook and it's a
wonderful benefit for Americans to have
such perceptive people Godfrey Hutchins
has been for much of his career a
journalist covering the United States he
did a important book on the election of
1968 when the country was then wracked
in turmoil over another war he's a
historian
he's a biographer he wrote a wonderful
biography of another colonel Colonel
Henry L Stimson and one of Senator
Daniel Patrick Moynihan and in doing
this book he served all of us a great
provided a great service because there's
a yale connection with the colonel house
because he through Charles Seymour who
was a part of the American delegation to
the Paris Peace Conference became close
friends and Charles Seymour
waited Colonel house to give his
extraordinary collection of papers
including marvelous diary to Yale and
they've been in the historical archives
at Yale for all these years since the
early 1920s and hundreds of students
graduate students professors writers
have drawn sustenance from that
collection but there has never been a
rounded biography until this time and in
this book and through the work of our
speaker we see not only the importance
of Colonel house at the time as
right-hand man to Woodrow Wilson during
the First World War but also how events
of that time are still resonating in the
problems all of us on this earth are
facing today so welcome to you Godfrey
glad to have you here thank thank you
very much nicer dad my thanks to
Professor yeah the Smith for his help on
this whole project from my first meeting
Sam I guess five years ago now I want to
start by asking why it is relevant now
to look at the life of Colonel house
there are I think a number of points
that I should make before I develop my
my argument the first is of the second
decade of the 20th century was a very
crucial decade it was the last time in
my opinion that the world was truly
malleable I mean the the world of
international politics was plastic mary
book would be changed and then as a
result of the failures at the end of the
first world war we all moved into a
consequential train of events which led
from war to revolution to economic
recession and depression to the rise of
fascism to war again
to Holocaust and to the Cold War and
it's only in the very last few years
that we thought we might be escaping
from this ominous sequence now a number
of people including some of the
reviewers of this book have compared
Carl has to karl rove the only
similarity that i can see is that they
were both from texas but it is certainly
the case that colonel has played a
crucial role in the development of a
style a way of handling international
affairs international relations which
the united states has followed not in
any kind of slavish or automatic way but
has generally followed ever since he was
the first of a sequence of presidential
advisors of whom harry hopkins in the
roosevelt administration with george
bundy kennedy's National Security
Advisor Henry Kissinger as been yet
Brzezinski you know are in the same
tradition and I think it's also
important to see how many of the vital
issues of international affairs today
first surfaced in those crucial years of
Colonel houses working political life
five years from 1914 to 1919 then as now
it was a question of American world
leadership it was a question of how
willing and how enthusiastic Americans
were to embrace that leadership and add
to and to accept its burdens there was
the question of what has come to be
known as wilsonian policy the idea that
it was the destiny and even the duty of
the United States to spread it's it's
version of democracy around the world
that is very much a live issue today
before the present administration in
Washington the Clinton administration
was explicitly wilsonian
there was a strange episode right at the
beginning of that of that administration
is being rather forgotten now in which
the president his UN Ambassador
Madeleine Albright his Secretary of
State Warren Christopher and Tony Lake
his national security adviser all made
speeches clearly in a coordinated
pattern to advocate what they called
wilsonian policies and of course
president george w bush has also adopted
that kind of other militant version of
the world Sounion dream but also I think
even behind these particular issues
there is a matter of the whole style and
tone with which the United States has
dealt with the rest of the world one key
factor in that has been the reluctance
to embrace professional diplomats and
operate as far as possible by a number
of people who'd who'd commended
themselves by work in other fields and
international law as academics as
bankers and as it used to be known as
dollar-a-year man as people who have so
much money they don't need to work for
wages in any case this began with a
strange encounter September the 24th
1911 when Woodrow Wilson who was running
for president of the United States paid
a brief visit to a private gentleman
from Texas who was living in an
apartment at the Gotham apartments on
East 53rd Street in Manhattan it was the
first time they'd met and the meeting
went well so well that within a year
Colonel house had become a key member of
Wilson's campaign team after Wilson was
inaugurated president house became his
intimate friend his trusted political
counselor and in effect his assistant
president for foreign policy the
friendship was not cronyism they didn't
play poker together like president
Carney Harding or President Truman with
their buddies but it was a remarkably
close friendship these two inhibited
Victorian southern
gentleman fun they could engage in long
honest conversations about beauty poetry
love and death that there's a vignette
which I cherish of these two gentlemen
being driven out to the Rock Creek
Cemetery in Washington which is not
actually close to Rock Creek it's on the
hill by the by the soldiers home in the
north of the district and there they sat
before august's and gardens wonderful
sculpture to commemorate Henry Adams his
wife clover and they had a long and very
personal conversation in front of that
astonishingly beautiful statue house
once dictated to his diary that he tried
all of his life to find quite someone
with whom he could work out the things
he had so deeply at heart he said he was
despairing of doing so when Wilson gave
him the opportunity for which I was
longing Wilson went even further mr.
house he said once is my second
personality he's my independent self his
thoughts and mine are one and it was as
if we had known each other forever now
there's a pretty striking
that's pretty striking language for a
powerful intellectual man who was by
then President of the United States and
I think the closeness of that friendship
as well as the achievements of that
friendship have tended to be blotted out
by pretty hostile press that that if one
can say oppress when one's talking about
historians and about the hostile
accounts that that have been given by
historians of Colonel house and of his
relationship with Woodrow Wilson in the
end as we shall see that friendship did
not endear but while it did last for the
seven years from 1912 to 1919 which was
a critical time not just in those two
men's lives but in the history of the
United States and indeed in the history
of the world the closest was not any
extraordinary it was a political fact of
Cardinal importance
Wilson trusted her
to the point of giving him authority of
the whole process of assembling his
administration with all the patronage
that conveyed from 1914 to 1919 has
spent much of his time in Europe as the
president's confidential emissary of you
like secret agent no private citizen
before or since has ever been given so
much authority by President to act on
his behalf on the world stage before the
world war began World War one began in
Europe house saw the German Kaiser and
the British government in an effort to
prevent the war he would have seen the
French government too if it hadn't been
distracted at the time by what is known
as a creaming posture now the wife of
the Finance Minister had walked into the
offices of the editor of the Figaro the
major newspaper and shot him dead over
the papers revelations of her love
letters after the war had started House
did everything he could to stop it
in particular he worked to bring about a
negotiated settlement but the European
powers were not ready for that and I
think the reason for that for me is
summed up in a casual remark made by one
of the senior diplomats that house has
become friendly with in London and house
was pressing the case for a negotiated
end of the war this man Sir William
Terrell reminded house that the second
of his two sons had been killed at the
front the previous week and people had
got so involved so angry so emotional
that the chances of the negotiated
settlement where were pretty remote the
Germans thought they didn't need one
because they thought they were going to
win and the British and French were
damned if they were going to have a
negotiated son but was they thought they
too would win in the end and they were
determined to do so after the United
States got into the war House did what
he could to ensure victory and after the
war was over he was the president's
trusted emissary and negotiating an
armistice to bring it to an end and at
the peace conference in Paris he was at
first
second only to Wilson as the most
influential delegate then things went
wrong Wilson lost confidence in him
there was no confrontational open brain
but house was effectually squeezed out
after Wilson's illness he didn't even
reply to houses letters that house was
not even invited by the winner to
Wilson's funeral Woodrow Wilson when he
first met house was running for
president as an unusual candidate only
three years before he was a highly
controversial president of Princeton
University he'd become Governor of New
Jersey he had already acquired a habit
of quarreling those with those who had
helped him which was not particularly
happy or useful habit and and one which
was for which Colonel house was to pay
dearly himself
Wilson cared little and knew little
about the practicalities of politics he
did understand that he needed to reach
out beyond the traditional Democratic
South and also beyond the wall street
men who were only too keen to help him
if you were to be elected as only the
second Democrat to be president since
the Civil War one Democrat before
president on two occasions but but he
would have been only the second he
wasn't in a second Democrat since
Appomattox Colonel house was not a
military man he was a Texas colonel
that's to say he'd been given the title
by a progressive governor of Texas firm
he work Jim Hogg he'd inherited some
wealth from his father an English
immigrant pastry-cook who built up a
fortune in land and business in Houston
before the Civil War house served Hogg
in Austin and he became the sort of
kingmaker behind three subsequent
governors of Texas he built up a sort of
genteel
unofficial machine of moderate to
conservative politicians in Texas but
his private views were increasingly
progressive ones Wilson offered in the
chance of going national and advising a
president as he had advised for
governors of Texas House did not make
Wilson president but through his friends
he did help to throw Texas his way which
was important he did keep William
Jennings Bryan on board
which was important because there was
still there was still those who would
have preferred to go down to defeat yet
again with Brian rather than to win with
somebody else and as it happened where
with Wilson and house did sort out a
very unpleasant and unnecessary quarrel
between the two joint managers of the of
the Wilson campaign Wilson was
sufficiently grateful that when he won
house became immediately the man to see
in the world administration Wilson could
not be bothered with the sordid details
of patronage he handed over all the
political inference that patronage gifts
to house who did a good and fair job but
did take care to place what he called
four or five warm personal friends in
key posts among them the State
Department the Treasury
the Department of Justice Department of
the Interior and the London embassy
which was a kind of a good start to
influence in any administration house
and his wife had been in the habit of
travelling in Europe so they already saw
the signs of approaching war more
clearly than many Americans did in the
summer of 1914 and he tried in a rather
extraordinary episode to prevent the war
his idea was to distract Germany Britain
and France from their quarrels and to
get them involved instead jointly with
the United States in low interest rate
investments in what house called the
wild places of the earth interestingly
that then included Mexico China and Iran
one of the ideas I think was that house
was anxious to to find fields for
development and for American investment
that were not part of the British and
French and other European empires
because that would have aroused a good
deal of resentment and resistance in
London and Paris and so he had this idea
which has a certain modern resonance of
using development as a way of bringing
together potentially rival powers it
might have worked
I not sure they really was likely to
work I'm very struck by the fact that
Sir Edward grey who became an intimate
friend of houses and who was a party to
this project doesn't in fact mention it
in his memoirs which I think suggests
that that grapes didn't take it quite as
seriously as Houston
in any case that's academic because then
the Archduke was murdered in Sarajevo it
was the beginning of June when when has
had a visit with with the Kaiser bizarre
meeting at Potsdam and by the end of
June the European system was falling
apart as as one path after another
mobilized its armed forces and didn't
know how to stop once the war had begun
the house was back in Europe again
seeing his friends in London seeing high
officials in Berlin and developing also
some important contacts in Paris after
complex negotiations he did get Sir
Edward grey to agree to a plan for a
negotiated peace the idea was that
President Wilson would convene a past
peace conference
if the Germans refused to go along then
Wilson would commit the United States to
fight with Britain and France and Russia
against Germany but Wilson agreed to
this scheme but he then wrote in the
word the United States would quote
probably unquote declare war on Germany
well nobody was really prepared to to
commit themselves to a deal when the
other party was only probably prepared
to go along with it
so although house loyally supported that
and so it was perfect the word probably
didn't didn't make any difference the
fact is it was fatal House was
disappointed he also reacted by being
very critical of the British for not
seizing the opportunity to end the war
he had tried to give them he quarreled
with the British quite a bit about the
the question of freedom of the seas
Americans since Jefferson had seen the
freedom of the seas as a as a legitimate
interest whereas the British and seniors
stripping them of their their great
weapon in international relations which
was they are voted
use the Royal Navy to boycott countries
that were hostile
in any case house shared Wilson's
distaste for traditional diplomacy and
specifically he shared though I don't
think with quite the same passion
Wilson's suspicions of the Allies plans
for post-war peace these plans were
enshrined in what came to be known as
the secret treaties and to a
considerable extent these secret
treaties were already deals whereby
Britain and France offered rewards to
Russia to Italy to remain here and to
Greece if they would come in in the war
on their side then they would be given
as well as financial rewards they will
be given hunks of the territory of the
of the central powers so house because
he agreed with this this need to have a
new approach to the post-war diplomacy
he went along with Wilson's call to set
up a body to study what American post
war aims ought to be and they set up
what was called the inquiry the idea was
to hammer out American war aims in line
with Wilson's ambition to use the war as
an opportunity to impose American ideals
on the world and to do so in what Wilson
saw as a more American way open
covenants openly agreed on it wasn't
that easy to find people who could
produce detailed papers on the post-war
situation in Europe and House was driven
back on to groups of people who I think
of as being the Brahmins and the excise
the Brahmins for those patrician many
New Englanders overwhelmingly from three
universities from this one from Harvard
and from Princeton who had actually
traveled in Europe some of them had
spent
either a german or french university and
many of them admitted that they had only
a fairly skin deep knowledge of the
politics in europe but they were
extremely able people many of whom went
on to have brilliant academic careers
wallace Notestine erratic red book about
Britt England ami a verge of Civil War
Charles Homer Hoskins great Homer
medievalist yes Colin of Princeton
constitutional authority and and many
other people the same same weight and I
think that that was the beginning of the
process that that has gone on ever since
which involved among other things taking
foreign policy out of the State
Department waited always lived before
and also bringing in outsiders to
support the president in his own foreign
policies and doing bringing in in
particular these two groups of people
academic pundits and specifically people
with special knowledge of European
problems and European countries because
they were refugees from those countries
and that's the beginning of a process
which leads us to Henry Kissinger and
his despiteful treatment of William
Rogers there's actually the state and
even more recently we've seen a
secretary of state in : powell
sidelined because he disagreed with the
president about policy as it happened
the ink were produced a huge body of
work including some you know impressive
pieces of research but its greatest
achievement came almost before it had
begun work because led by walter
Lippmann who was involved the inquiry
people and came up with a draft for what
became President Wilson's I suppose most
famous speech the 14 points speech what
happened was that Lippmann and others
from the inquiry produced a truth
draft papers house came down from knee
or he refused to move to Washington by
the way there's a continue to live in
either in New York or or in a cottage on
the North Shore of Massachusetts
throughout and and he came down with
this draft and the he sat down and he
said yes he boasted in his diary we sat
down to work at half past 10:00 in the
morning and we finished remaking the map
of the world at half-past twelve now
they were able to do so because the they
draft of the speech which has helped
Wilson with who was very closely based
on the inquiries paper and some of the
historians who are critical of houses in
front son listen and critical or or
simply deny that he had great influence
have to attempted to deny this but
actually if you read the two papers side
by side it's extremely plain that the
fourteen point speech was closely based
on the inquiries report houses influence
was even greater perhaps on an even more
important vision of Wilson's and that
was the drafting of the Covenant of the
League of Nations the idea for something
like a League of Nations was not new it
had been kicking around before the war
and during the war in Europe both in
Britain and in France it was very much
an idea whose time had come
houses role was to shape an idea into a
specific policy and to produce a policy
paper which was the beginning of the
process of hammering out a League of
Nations which could be accepted by the
major European powers or at least by the
Allied powers they met house and Wilson
wasn't and mrs. Wilson came up in the
presidential yacht to the North Shore
and the two men met together on the
larger of the Jefferson Coolidge mansion
which is alas no longer that beautiful
home yeah houses vacation home and
looking out over the ocean
surrounded by papers drafts manuscripts
reports of all kinds they jointly
prepared the first draft of the Covenant
House had long thought that if Germany
continued to count on her new big
submarines to sink the ships that could
starve Britain art the United States
would not in the end be able to keep out
of the war Wilson of course famously
said there is such a thing as being too
proud to fight in the end it took the
Zimmermann telegram to overcome even
Wilson's reluctance to fight in it when
it was intercepted by British
intelligence the German government was
caught proposing to bribe the Mexicans
to join the war and to invade and
recapture California Arizona New Mexico
and Texas with the help of the Japanese
not a project that any American
president could easily ignore once the
United States was at war house went back
to Europe again he failed to get the
Allies to act together as he'd hoped but
his great success and house was his
agent in it it was to persuade the
Germans to agree to an armistice on the
basis of the fourteen points now they
played fair and straight with the
European allies they didn't conceal what
they were doing from Britain and France
but what they did was it was to to say
that the Germans could have an armistice
if they would accept the fourteen points
now there were a number of elements in
the fourteen points that the British and
the French would have liked to argue
about but Wilson and House put them in a
position where if they did so they
risked finding that the United States
would leave them to fight on a loan and
they therefore were not realistically
likely to refuse this deal so it is
really a brilliant diplomatic coup and
carried out in a way that didn't
actually upset or or annoy the Allies by
the way Wilson refused to call Britain
or France Allies there because
associated powers
because because they were such bad boys
every secret treaties and in any case
and that was I think a remarkable stroke
of diplomatic skill the that's when the
trouble began so far so good
in February 1919 Wilson had to go back
to Washington from France to be present
at the end of the congressional session
he left house in charge and in a
20-minute meeting house said he thought
he could button things up and he used
that phrase and had everything ready for
the president's approval when he
returned now they went through a number
of areas I think there were five or six
specific areas and they discussed what
approach house should take on each of
them there is a suggestion that Wilson
was a little alarmed by the alacrity
with which Colonel house said leave it
to me but in any case House was very
careful and correct in saying that of
course he couldn't decide anything
without the president's permission when
the president came back a month later
everything had gone wrong and everything
proceeded to go wrong Wilson had just
discovered how suspicious and bulky this
Senate was and particularly he realized
as he might have done before that Henry
Cabot Lodge was the new Republican
majority leader as well as the as the
chairman of the Foreign Relations
Committee and then any Lord who was his
enemy and then added an academic quarrel
over and Arteaga Henry Cabot Lodge was
the editor of the journal and turned
down an article which Wilson had written
and that as we know in the academic life
is not easily forgotten and so Wilson up
to that point it's simply I believe not
understood
how decisive his loss of control of the
two houses of Congress in the midterm
elections had been and here again we we
face a situation where there may be a
parallel in our immediate future but in
any case Wilson had been ad you lated in
Paris huge crowds had turned out he'd
been admired he'd been praised he'd seen
himself correctly as the arbiter of the
world for this brief moment of the turn
from 1918 to 1919 and I don't think he
seems to have really absorbed how
catastrophic loss of control of Congress
would be faced if he were going to
achieve his his plans in fact there's a
rather bizarre episode when President
Wilson was coming over on the boat to
Europe he was traveling with a number of
young bright members of the of the
inquiry and one of them William C bullet
said rather cheekily he said mr.
president we've been cooped up and in
steerage and and we'd really like to
have a have a talk with you and so they
had a meeting and Wilson explained that
the people he was going to be dealing
with in Europe did not have his
democratic legitimacy well Lloyd George
just won that control of the House of
Commons with 80% of the seats that by
far the highest margin anybody's ever
achieved in history and georges
clemenceau had just been confirmed as
prime minister of france but with the
votes of 80 percent of the assembly
whereas Wilson has just been heavily
defeated in both houses of Congress but
Wilson's temperament I mean that was
there those were details he was it was
his vision which was got to be inscribed
on the future of the world there was no
immediate breach according to the second
mrs. Wilson Wilson was horrified that
house had made too many compromises the
phrase she used in her other novel Etta
SH memoirs was what was House has given
away everything I have
for and but in any case it's quite plain
that there was increasing tension
between the two men there was no
immediate breach Wilson house continued
to work together when Wilson was ill
which he was twice house stood in as his
deputy but clearly the old trust was
broken and the intimate friendship was
over why well part of the explanation
lies in the deep suspicions that Edith
Wilson had harbored of Colonel Haas as a
result of an episode of that crucial
moment in her life when she was about to
get married to the President of the
United States and at this point rumors
surfaced about some letters that would
err wasn't to had written to a lady
called of mrs. Mary Peck who was a
lively divorcee that wasn't it met in
Bermuda I cherished a wonderful picture
that survives that of that of mrs. Peck
and Wilson mrs. Peck is leaning forward
as all alike none of those pictures in
society now scenes but the caption says
mrs. sands are enjoying a joke with mr.
somebody and whatever adds in the nature
of the relationship it's clear that
Wilson was to some extent in love with
Mary Peck it's not clear whether what is
known as physical intimacy took place
but what is quite certain is that Wilson
gave mrs. Peck very substantial amount
of money and he did suddenly feel very
guilty about it he wrote sewing in the
paper for his own first to clarify his
own feelings or other historical payment
Edith Wilson blamed house for the
surfacing of these love letters now it
is nothing perfectly true that Colonel
has regretted the fact that President
Wilson was getting remarried so soon
after his first wife's death and so
shortly before a presidential election
but as it happens it wasn't House
who surfaced who leaked the letters that
was done by William Gibbs McAdoo who
happened to be both the secretary of the
Treasury and Wilson's campaign manager
and also his son-in-law but the fact is
that the spell was broken that from the
spring of 1919 on Wilson house were no
longer close trusting political friends
there was of course more to the falling
out then that's old story about the love
letters
Wilson was clearly ill more ill than
anybody knew he had he had already had a
series of strokes of increasing severity
they seemed and some you know
psychiatrists have have written that
these strikes had changed his
personality that he was less open more
trying more paranoid and as a result of
this these medical problems he suddenly
had his head had been turned by the
reception he had received in Europe he
thought that he and he alone could bring
about a new order in which the world's
peace would be guaranteed by exporting
American ideals house though discreet
and loyal was not uncritical he confided
to his diary that he thought he could
solve things are better than than Wilson
could and some visits were less discreet
he was the bridge between the two
friends was bitterly painful for house
Wilson never showed any forgiveness or
gratitude to be fair he was mortally
tired and before long desperately ill
but this was not just a private tragedy
has needed Wilson and it's clear that
has in a measure in Paris forgot that
his whole infants depended on
maintaining Wilson's trust without the
president the president's advisor is all
nothing but Wilson - needed house has
understood that it wasn't was to create
a new European indeed a new world system
based on American ideals the consent of
the governed open democracy
self-determination of people's he had a
beast at least better find out what the
existing world was really like and he
should also be more realistic than he
was about the politics of his own
country as it was worsens dreams
evaporated and has his hopes with them
it is a sad story but but why as I began
by asking is it relevant a fast today
well for one thing even if you do not
think as many people used to think of as
I do noting that the defeat of the
League of Nations led directly to the
rise of National Socialism there is no
question that a great opportunity for
building a structure of peace was lost
in Paris in 1919 there was plenty of
blame to go around for that I mean the
French were terrified of the research a
possible resurgence of Germany did after
all been invaded by the Germans twice in
a short period of time and and we're
going to be invaded by them again the
French and the Italians were really in
their demands for reparations the
British were pursuing their own
interests and rather indifferent to they
I think was cynical about the prospects
of building a wilsonian world but
Wilson's vision and idealism would have
benefited I believe from houses common
sense and realism I don't use the word
realism in the technical sense in which
it's used in departments of
international relations but it was all
very well for exam to take an example to
denounce secret diplomacy but it was
quite another thing to lecture the
peoples of Europe as Wilson did
repeatedly and this house kept urging
him not to do about the need not to be
selfish after all Wilson's interests in
this our situation but the greatest of
all Wilson wanted nothing less than
the United States to be the most in
disputed have power in the in the world
for himself to be the arbiter of its of
its future so it was rather unhelpful to
keep giving speech he used to write this
phrase about being not being selfish
into every smidgen husband that truly
take it out the second decade of the
20th century sounds a long time ago and
perhaps especially for Americans who
write they like to focus on the future
rather than the past and you know it
does seem very remote but it was in many
ways a time that bought a surprising
resemblance to our own it was first
started age of globalization when trade
and transportation were bringing the
peoples of the earth closer than ever
before it was time of dizzying
technological change radio movies
aviation all invented in the 20 years
previous twenties before the war began
it was an age of angry nationalism new
nations Japan China Mexico were
challenging traditional structures of
power demanding a seat at the table if
you like it was an age of revolution
when new peoples the Russians the
Chinese the Irish the peoples of the
collapsing Ottoman Empire in the Middle
East and the peoples of the Balkans all
pressing their claims to be heard and
that claimed to govern themselves that
second decade was I think as I said the
last time before our own when the
world's political system did seem
malleable it was the beginning of what
Eric Hobsbawm has called the short 20th
century this long sequence of that of
unfortunate events our loss to pay drew
notes oh wait a minute
we forgetting forgetting town let's find
this page 9 yeah for 70 years afterwards
as Hobbs one showed the world spun down
grooves of ominous change world war
communism economic breakdown fascism
world war genocide nuclear nightmare
cold war if we're not to repeat the
failures of Wilson's and houses dreams I
believe we must look much more closely
what went wrong at the beginning of that
sequence this was the moment when the
United States found itself for the first
time bearing the burdens of a world
system that had just broken down for
great imperial autocracies the russian
the austro-hungarian the ottoman and the
Prussian had collapsed utterly the
imperial democracies Britain France and
Italy was a grievously drained of
resources that they lost any capacity to
restore the system only in the United
States emerged from the war stronger and
with a convincing vision of how the
world might be Wilson's vision was well
well Sounion he wanted to impose on the
world by moral influence if possible but
if not by political and even military
power American ideals as he saw them I
think one interesting way of looking at
the difference between Woodrow Wilson
and Android house was that Wilson saw
the world's a blank page on which he
could scroll his theorems of what ought
to be or what might be
but how saw the world more as a map of
realities mountains rivers cities
provinces people's interests that might
be surmounted but had to be dealt with
before they could be surmounted asand
and Wilson certainly shared ideals but
where Wilson was a visionary an idealist
an iambic rhetorician house was a
realist a pragmatist a negotiation ago
she a tyrannical
physical actor the lessons of that time
love their ultimately failed the
leverage or many heat the best way I can
sum them up is by reading to the last
paragraph of this book houses failures I
wrote were large and obvious but they
were not all his own he understood
earlier and more clearly than Wilson
that the United States was too strong
and at the same time its strength was
too bound up with the fate of other
countries in migration in trade in many
other ways to remain aloof from the
world's urgent moral conflicts he was
sure too that America's entry onto the
world scene could best be achieved not
by boasting about the exceptional
virtues of American society but by
finding partners in other societies who
would work towards the same goals thank
you be my own chair
quite seriously he he of course he had
quite a close friendship with Arthur
Balfour but he also was a friend of Hein
weitzman and he kept in touch with
several of the Zionist leaders of the
time he wasn't particularly well he
wasn't knowledgeable at all about the
state of affairs on the ground in
Palestine or indeed in the Middle East
as a whole he in his diary you get a
picture of a whirlwind of people I mean
he sometimes lists the people he's seen
er they'd seen 30 people you know that
the rather wanton queen of Romania Arryn
and some African leader and a couple of
barons from the Japanese diplomatic
service and and three American
journalists and a travelling senator
it's quite extraordinary I mentioned to
keep all these these balls in the air
but there isn't really very much in his
correspondence or diary about the detail
of the Middle East what is true of
course is that I mean the the the
British and the French were not fools
they were aware that Wilson was against
dealing in provinces as if they were the
stakes on the poker table so what they
said is they they just they they didn't
ask for anything when the French asked
for for as Iceland but that obviously
they were gonna get that anyway and the
French also wanted guarantees against
Chairman the resurgence and they wanted
reparations but they didn't ask for
anything much otherwise for themselves
what the French said they wanted there
was an influence over some of the
Ottoman Empire's Asiatic provinces as
specifically over Syria and Lebanon and
at the same time the British said well
oh we don't have any real interest but
we'd love to have a mandate to preserve
the future and encourage democracy in in
Arabia and Palestine and Mesopotamia
which is now Iraq but of course what
they ended up setting up was more or
less traditional colonial structures in
Egypt Arabia what's now Jordan Palestine
and Iraq now say more or less colonial
structures because most of the other
colonial territories were not in fact
very highly structured administrations
they were mostly sort of pretty likely
ruled and and the same was true in the
Iraq of nineteen Twenty twenty one
twenty two and there's a wonderful
moment when Winston Churchill who was
then the minister responsible probably
Minister for the colonies and he wrote a
he wrote a note to sir Arnold Wilson who
was there they kind of probe at
proconsul in charge of Iraq saying I'm
can you please explain to me what is the
difference between the Sunni and the
Shia well there was a piece in the op-ed
page of the New York Times yes he
explained that people in Washington have
quite Scott so the answer is not a lot
of detail but that but a reluctance
really to grapple I mean I mean a truly
wilsonian Wilson it seems to me would
have said we've got to talk about this
we believe that that colonial empires
are wrong and we're not going to support
you in maintaining or
or continuing them let alone reimposing
them
Wilson didn't do that partly because he
was not a detail man he really wasn't
and partly because he was not very well
and he didn't have much energy and and
partly because he'd suddenly woken up to
find their one of his worst enemies
never had him by the throat and I think
well somebody suggested to me the other
day that I underestimated the extent to
which Wilson deliberately blamed house
and because he saw that things were
going wrong and he wanted to shift some
of the burden on ttis on somebody else
right
right
no I forget the details but there's a
there's a point in which Wilson simply
I'm not sure whether it's the Balfour
Declaration itself or a memorandum about
it and he Wilson literally finds it in
his pocket where it's been sitting for
weeks because and he he he memos house
saying oh by the way does this this is
paper you gave me about the Jews I don't
know what it's important or not I mean
he really was not you might have been
sympathetic in theory to Zionism but it
wasn't at all high on his priorities
that's true
right but I mean do you disagree with my
general point which was that there's
remarkably little detailed attention to
the Middle East and in the conference
true
but but for example I was struck by how
he never really analyzed the concept of
self-determination - two points one is
he didn't distinguish between the
self-determination of Nations and the
self-determination of people's which
sound as if they're the same that are
very different in practice and the other
is that in almost every case where a new
nation was created in Paris or allowed
to create itself because that's more
accurate in some cases and that new
nation contains people's who did not
determine their future a classic example
being Yugoslavia but the same is also
true of the new Poland and in particular
of Czechoslovakia and you could go
around and find that that I mean of
course Wilson was a you know an erudite
historian and scholar but but it doesn't
seem to me he focused on the detail at
all whereas house had a personal
intelligence service of people sort of
feeling stuff in to him about what was
going on in many many parts of the world
and he was dealing I think as a
practicing politician does know that
responding to some extent the intensity
of pressure and one of the things that
struck me for example is that has was
getting letters from one of the Czech
Legion as they were fighting their way
across Siberia and that was only one
element in the extraordinary jigsaw
puzzle of of Russia in 1919 but the idea
that has it equipped himself with an
informant who was adding a captain or a
major in there and these irregular Czech
forces I thought was quite extraordinary
any of the comments yeah
yeah well yes let's try that and the
question is how much Sigmund Freud had
to do with it
I think bullet went and interviewed
Freud and got some ideas and and then
proceeded to write it a pretty nasty in
hostile short but which does have some
indeed Freudian insights but it's not a
serious piece of psychoanalysis let
alone of that psycho biography the
georges book i I read it I didn't think
it was bad I didn't feel it I learned
him particularly from it what it were is
very interesting as she's the various
medical papers attached and to the
Wilson papers as from any one or two
volumes of of papers written by
psychiatrists and and neurologists and
others about the probable personality
consequences of persons illnesses and in
Phyllis Levin's excellent book there's a
rather a judicious sort of sifting of
those of those different opinions
I think Wilson did feel guilt I think
the greatest as literature the greatest
of his speeches is the last one when he
talks about those dear ghosts who still
deploy among the fields of France it's a
astonishing speech I also think that I
think that he well I don't think he saw
himself as responsible for the lives of
American soldiers killed I think he saw
himself as the man who done all he could
to prevent it and the fact of the matter
is that's true I mean Wilson really went
on gosh had to put it in an unfriendly
way squirming away from one situation
after another one
almost everybody including house said my
god we really do have to get into the
war now starting with the Lusitania
crisis and I ride on until I mean even
after even after the Zimmermann telegram
there's a matter of weeks before Wilson
could be brought up to actually accept
that this had happened you're right he
were he saw this as the as the failure
the frustration of his vision and and no
harm in that but at the same time I
don't think he by an interpreter of his
personalities he was not somebody who
spent a lot of time worrying about his
personal guilt I don't know that's my
impression
I've gotten this I think that Stimson
made a speech at Yale which in which she
said there was a privilege for those who
would go and fight and die for for
liberty and that George Herbert Walker
Bush rushed out and joined the Navy
underage on the strength of listening to
that speech now in 1940 in June 1940 he
made a speech and he made two speeches
one at Phillips Andover and one Yale and
I'm not sure which one drove at the
young Bush into this
really
right
well what did I I have no direct
personal expertise at all in this field
thank God
what the what the doctors say is that
number one that Wilson had a history of
cardiovascular disease which started
with a stroke severe enough to have
affected his seeing his eyesight quite a
long time earlier I think I mean
nineteen 1906 I think 1909 after get
rich but wait way but before the war
long before he was he was elected and
that he then had a series of
increasingly severe cardiovascular
incidents including what is now
diagnosed as a a stroke in Paris in the
spring and then the the almost fatal one
in Colorado on their on the tour
in September I guess that the consensus
seems to be that his political skills
were affected that he was more impatient
more he clearly was he remained for
example an astonishing the vivid and
effective speaker but he was more
impatient more less willing to sit down
with people no listen to what they had
to say more inclined to promote his own
ideas rather than meeting people
anywhere near halfway that that seems to
me that that the pattern of the of the
change but but it does it is I think
ever every witness agreed that that he
was a changed man from as the dating is
rather peculiar because the visit to
Washington which was a catastrophic mr.
wall everything went badly wrong and it
was from February the 14th to
March the 15th I think and with two bits
of nice relaxing ocean travel on either
end and two weeks of everything going
wrong in Boston and Washington and he
came back from that and mrs. Wilson's
aunt suggests that he was just horrified
within the first moments of talking to
the French ambassador and then to house
on the train he then had two severe
illnesses one a kind of flu with a very
high temperature which have a lasted
only about two days and then another
illness rather mysteriously described
which doctors now seemed to think was a
major cardiovascular incident and these
these were quite close together but they
were after the return and if you are if
you accept Edith Wilson's account to
these things his owners may well have
been the consequence of the shock at
seeing the appalling betrayal which
Colonel has had committed but my own
view is that is that these were separate
medical incidents brought on problem by
the general stress and exhaustion of the
conference because everybody it was a
madhouse having any big conference if
you go to a professional conference it
lasts four days it's pretty exhausting
you stay up late at night you talk to
too many people you have too many drinks
and whatever and in this case this went
on for months
and there was some extremely tough
cookies pushing and bucking and shelling
for what they wanted that very often
with with their rather narrow obsessions
where as poor Wilson and indeed Colonel
house - were trying to trying to bring
the whole thing together and to satisfy
all of these conflicting obsessions so
it's entirely plausible to me that it
was both the shock of of being roughed
up by
Henry Cabot Lodge and other services the
dinner party was an absolute disaster
one of the things that went wrong is
that Wilson only served
Apollinaris water and these fellows I
mean they were really not used to not
having decent wine to drink and they
also the cigars were not very good so
several senators noted and and this was
not the vice president's concern for a
decent five cent cigar we're talking
about serious Havana's that they were
used to and finally Henry Cabot Lodge
notice that the first lady's fingernails
were dirty it was really very ugly
bad-tempered horrible and so that is
part of the building stress on Wilson
and then I mean the discovery that his
great vision was going to have to be
fought through not only the Peace
Conference in Paris but also the Senate
of the United States that was stressful
and then I think the sheer exhaustion of
the thing continued and then finally he
goes out to try to save his vision of
the league in particular and he travels
thousands of miles he makes I think
about a dozen major speeches and by this
stage he's in terrible shape medically
as well as politically
well I think one thing about house is he
he said Judas Lee avoided the limelight
I think he really did try to avoid the
limelight although in the end he got a
lot of press coverage and and he was
irritated by some of it and rightly so I
think he I think one of the keys to
understanding his personality and I
don't feel very confident about this
least of all in presence of his grandson
but I think he was he was not strong as
a child he had a an incident way he fell
and damaged himself as a child he find
it very hard to take the hot weather in
Texas pre air-conditioning and he seems
to have sort the secondary role the the
role of influence rather than the role
of executive authority and I think
that's genuine there is one rather
puzzling more than one actually a couple
of times in the diary where he he sort
of says my god I broke my legs by
tripping over a cable I'm doing this and
again he Tammany says what I could have
been made senator from Texas because
this is before direct election and if
I'd been senator well I might have been
a presidential candidate so gosh I
wonder what I would liked being
president but I don't think he he ever
seriously sought that kind of authority
what he loved to feel like it was
that he thought he was insider of course
and that he was influential but also I
think I think he did have his own set of
ideals which again if there's this
puzzling episode of the book that he
wrote philip drew and when he wrote it
it was immediately after his first
meeting with wilson actually after two
or three meetings with a person when
clearly the relationship of the rustman
was going to be very important in his
life he then falls sick which he did
from time to time and he goes off to
Texas and and and at very high speed he
writes down this book which he's been
thinking about and working on for months
because when McAdoo and I go see him
they say oh that house is full of sort
of though research papers and maps and
statistics and so what can this man be
up to and it's clear he'd been using a
lot of his time to study and then at
racing speed he writes his peculiar book
which is which is partly a sort of
Victorian novel about Phillip drew and
his love affair and partly is a sort of
manifesto for a a rather tough minded
progressive government and it includes a
interesting episode which I think
reflects some of the political culture
of the south at that time in which a
senator who has been often seen as being
derived from marcus a hannah is ceiling
everybody blind and so philip drew
raises an army in the southwest and they
in a great battle somewhere in Indiana
and they defeat the forces of the hammer
figure and they march on Washington and
and philip drew arrives that at his
inference as it was as a victor of
a military campaign and and it's I think
it's easy to see that Colonel house is
somebody who had been sort of an invalid
much of his life was was working out a
fantasy of being a as well conquering
military hero it's an interesting book
very peculiar book it doesn't doesn't
work as a novel at all but it's full of
interesting ideas
well the comparison is hot enough in the
world the world of 1914 was very
different from the world of 1990 in 1914
you had a sort of a polycentric world in
which there were half a dozen Great
Powers Britain France Russia Germany
austria-hungary and the Ottoman Empire
beginning to disappear and the United
says having to join the company of those
bars by 1919 the United States was
immeasurably the most powerful if only
because American industry had done
extremely well others supplying me that
villager in Powers and American
financier done extremely well out of the
funding the war the the world of 1919
was a much more it was a much less
egalitarian world it was essentially a
world still attempting to preserve 19th
century conventions of behavior and and
also political ideals and everything
that's happened that whole sequence I'd
mentioned I just tossed a my talk that
begins with the breakdown of the
European system and which ends up well
you know before 9/11 there was eleven
nine there was the fall of the Berlin
Wall and that is if you like that and
they and the collapse of the Soviet
Union three years later on the ends of
that of that process so that the changes
wrought in the world by that sequence of
disastrous events between 1914 and 1991
the changes is so hard that I couldn't
describe them in and in a 90 minute talk
let alone in a in a few minutes and
after the lessons we've learned from
them my god I sound as one over that I
think we're still in pursuit of those
ideals which which are wilsonian but
also pre wilsonian the the ideals of a
structured piece of organization which
would be able both to you know to
develop economically the various nations
of the world so they would move be more
closely equal and that that would
eliminate those sources of conflict that
arose from from mere hunger and
desperation so there's that kind of
economic melee arisen which which which
is a thread that runs through this whole
period and at the same time there is
this other thread which is the argument
between liberal democracy and it's
sundry enemies now whether we can be
sort of learned any lessons I think I
think people who learn specific lessons
they've learned lessons about how to
conduct diplomacy about communications
about many things but but whether we've
learned lessons in the sense of any
closer to getting these things right is
I fear I very much done